it's simply so overwhelming it's hard to
put into words
pakistan
is drowning
an area of land that is the equivalent
of the whole of the uk
is under water
our team is witnessing a mass exodus of
people made homeless in their own
homeland
but there's nowhere to go there is water
everywhere
these people have been on the move for
days
their children are all ill but there's
no money for a doctor or medication
personality
some people have managed to stay at
least close to where they once lived and
called home they work on these fields
it's a huge agricultural expanse of land
but it is extremely dry and it's an
island they are surrounded by vast
expanses of water and muddy bogs you
cannot even walk through it to get to
the main road
as we were driving we saw an entire
village of people wading through the
water
they had tied their beds to tires as
makeshift rafts
abandoning their homes they salvage what
they can
people have not just lost their homes
but their livelihoods too
and they are frustrated the aid is not
coming through
kane
[Music]
foreign
the people here in sindh like millions
of others up and down the country are
finding what little dry land they can
on riverbanks
in muddy fields
and on roadsides
for now
this is home